all right
at least four people were killed as
Crystal gemancing Reports the fresh
round of air strikes is adding pressure
to the west to punish Iran and deliver
more military aid to Ukraine
disturbing cell phone video some
confirmed and some not yet verified
flooded social media
the images showing the terrifying and
deadly unmanned drones deployed by
Russia
so-called Kamikaze drones are designed
to explode on impact Ukraine's Air Force
claims more than 40 of the iranian-made
devices were deployed Monday morning
ukrainians responded by trying to shoot
the drones out of the sky
start of the week brought with it
another frantic search for survivors
we came here after getting a phone call
from our mother who said she was under
the rubble she said please find someone
urgently to help me their mother stopped
answering the phone
we were in the room when the blast
started then we go out to see the
staircases gone all gone down to the
ground floor firefighters eventually
rescued them using ladders Russians is
their their country I'm more than sure
do you see the unguilty people killed
every day in not just on Keith
everywhere anyway Russia says it hit
military command sites Communications
and energy infrastructure with
long-range High Precision weapons like
many ukrainians the foreign affairs
minister heeded the warning sirens and
sought safety underground Demetrio
caliba posted to social media that he
might be the first to address us the
European Union from a bomb shelter
Ukraine wants the EU to sanction Iran
for selling drones to Russia Iran denies
the sale and the EU is investigating the
United States one of Ukraine's biggest
weapons suppliers meanwhile is keeping
the focus on Russia this war can end
today this is a war that contend right
now today if if Vladimir Putin wants it
to nearly eight months into this war and
every day comes with a threat
Crystal commencing Global News London